so one of the questions we are asked
most is where do we get music for our
videos and the answer to that is simple
I actually make about ninety-nine
percent of it there's exceptions here
and there like dubstep guns and stuff
like that but I pretty much do it all
right here with our setup so here's the
basic process for when I write music for
a video I start with the final cut of
the piece and I bring it into my program
of choice Logic Pro from there I give it
a couple listens figure out where the
dynamics figure out where the music
needs to be loud soft fast slow all that
stuff and then I just start messing
around with a couple things you know
just hitting around on the piano for a
bit you know finding some cool chords I
like maybe playing on the guitar low
once I have kind of achieved that or
found something that sounds cool take it
run with it repeat it make some
variations and eventually polish it off
onto a final piece of music now logic is
a program that allows you to do a
variety of things you can record
instruments and microphones into it
directly you can hook up a MIDI keyboard
such as the one I have here and you can
also just work with pre-existing audio
files that you can just drop in there so
in order to do this there's a couple
pieces of very important equipment that
I like to use in order to actually get
sound in the computer such as recording
a microphone or guitar I like to use an
audio interface basically you can take
one of these things and just plug it in
with a USB you can put microphones in
here using an XLR cord you can plug
guitars into them as well
just through the the jack on the back of
a guitar and that brings it all right
into the program another thing is the
keyboard this is a USB powered keyboard
that inputs MIDI notes basically MIDI
notes are simply just keystrokes which
correspond to different notes and all
that stuff here's an example of the
keyboard running through a drum sample
so these drum samples I'm using are
actually recorded from real drums
basically someone took a microphone and
a drum kit and recorded each one in a
clean environment making it sound super
realistic and that's why I like to use
them it also allows you to run through
other virtual instruments
another couple useful things to have are
usually a good microphone this one I use
for both sound design recording voices
vocals everything and sometimes like
acoustic guitars this just plugs right
into the audio interface also when
writing your music you want to
accurately hear what you're writing
these headphones and these speakers are
specially designed to accurately portray
the sound that means they don't add any
extra treble or bass and they really
just play for you exactly what you're
meant to hear so how does all this stuff
work together let me show you I can take
my video file here and I can load it
right into the program which allows me
to essentially just scrub through this
musical timeline while watching the
video usually I can start by taking this
keyboard and I can like loop it through
yeah a drum sample of some sort like
this and record that and start layering
pieces over that
so once I've got my first track in there
I can start adding things on top of it
such as like a synthesizer bassline or
some sort I've got a pretty good base to
start adding more things on top of you
know I've got a rhythm I got a beat and
I've got a couple notes in there who had
a guitar track in or something like that
all I have to do is basically plug my
guitar directly into that audio
interface I was talking about now if you
listen to the guitar right now it sounds
kind of plain that's because you're
hearing the raw electric guitar sound
going right out of the speakers one
filter I like to use in particular is
called Guitar Rig it does an excellent
job of making your electric guitar sound
very realistic and there's a lot of
styles you can do anything from just
like normal distortion to more like
heavy distorted lead or something like
that
taking that and now adding it to the
piece I've already recorded I can
hopefully make something sound cool or
really stupid depending on how this goes
now with all together I can play it back
and hear what I just made so nothing too
crazy yet but I'm only just forgetting
usually takes a lot of refinement and
polish to kind of get something sounded
good you need a lot of layers in it in
musical complexity to kind of get that
rich sound
check this out every single time we
release the video I usually include a
iTunes and/or Bandcamp link which allows
you to get a song for like a dollar and
basically you can use them any way you
wish there's a Creative Commons license
essentially that allows it for you guys
to use in your own videos as long as
there's no ads on them you can do
whatever you want you can chop it up mix
it put it in your soundtrack do anything
you want at this point we have about
over 50 videos so there's kind of a
selection but you know if you're in need
of music just take a look through that
and maybe there's something they'll fit
so I hope you guys learn something from
that and maybe gained a little bit of
insight onto the music writing process
wait hold on before you close that
window you want to see more cool music
breakdowns like the one from insta-kill
click here at the tip of my bass guitar
if you don't see that button turn
annotations on or check out the link in
the description also if you want to
check out the music that I make you can
visit our soundcloud page which has a
link somewhere in my vicinity if you
want to check out our band camp page
there's another link in our vicinity and
if you want to see our stuff on iTunes
just search for my name Sam borsky on
iTunes you'll find all our music there
if you have any questions about the gear
I'm using samples programs whatever hit
us up on Twitter at court or digital and
if 140 characters isn't long enough for
you send us an email see you guys
what run it's on the button Rikki's
there's a button right there's a button
for it but yeah it's on it's on the
screen there you go
there you go it'll be early there
you